sometimes like in the case of birds and
insects migration is built into the very
DNA they migrate because their bodies
tell them to but for ungulates such as
deer sheep and moose it's long been
hypothesized that seasonal migration is
a learned behavior passed down from one
generation to the next the question is
do they innately know to go where the
best greenest healthiest grazing is at
different times of the year but do they
need to learn from others in the herd
researchers have now put this to the
test by tracking the movements of
bighorn sheep and moose in the American
West
they used GPS data of hoof stop for both
historic populations centuries old in
some cases populations that had been
moved over the past few decades due to
overhunting and disease
the researchers tracked the way these
different types of herds migrated over
two to four years and compared how their
movements matched up with the quality of
the available food in the area ideally
when ungulates migrate they synchronized
their movements to forage for vegetation
and its most nutritious and easiest to
digest a process called green wave
surfing and the American West that means
as the weather warms they follow the
best fodder from lower elevations to
higher ones following the best greens up
the mountain see the research team used
NASA's møtes' satellite to take
snapshots of the greenery over time
while an onboard spectrometer analyzed
the forage quality researchers then
overlaid the data from the animals
movements gleaned from GPS collars with
these maps of forage quality they
defined an animal surfing ability as the
difference between the day forged
quality peaked and the day the animal
forged at the location this map follows
three historic herds of bighorn sheep
from whiskey basin Wyoming as the
vegetation begins to mature having lived
there for centuries they easily follow
the vegetation as improves up the
mountain
this map however follows three relocated
herds of sheep eighty-five miles to the
north in Devil's Canyon Wyoming since
they've only lived there for a short
time they haven't yet learned to green
wave surf so they stay put the results
showed that historic populations were
much better at riding the Greenway in
populations that have been recently
relocated suggesting that green wave
surfing migration is learned or
culturally transmitted is likely this
ability takes decades to develop as each
generation becomes familiar with the
area and passes down this knowledge to
their offspring however once a species
is relocated or driven locally extinct
due to disease or over hunting that
knowledge is lost forever and could take
decades to be restored though this study
is only based on a few herds the
researchers believe that this emphasizes
the importance of not only establishing
new migration corridors for relocated
species but also preserving ones that
have already existed for in some cases
centuries
[Music]
you
[Music]